[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Карпати, Бабин
Хата-Майстерня]
У нас вже була компанія людей,
які робили всякі проєкти.
Ми по всій Україні тоді мігрували,
і у нас був період, коли після цього моменту
кочівництва нам захотілося десь укорінитися.
[Альона Каравай
Співзасновниця Хати-Майстерні]
Ми сказали: «Хочемо мати спільну базу».
Ми хочемо мати хату, до якої можемо приїжджати.
Можемо там щось проводити чи не проводити.
А потім почався Євромайдан,
почалася війна і
в якийсь момент, коли все рушилось,
захотілося робити.
І просто не знаючи, що буде з країною,
хлопці приїхали сюди,
дівчата теж трошки.
Просто почали будувати тоді,
коли не було зрозуміло,
чи є де будувати і, взагалі, що відбуватиметься далі.
Це була така реакція,
бо будували ми в 2014 році.
Коли деякі з наших колег виїжджали з Криму,
а хтось — зі сходу України.
Просто приїжджали сюди і будували.
Можна сказати, що проєкт, такий, як він став, спочатку таким не планувався.
[Тарас Ковальчук
Співзасновник Хати-Майстерні]
Що це буде така Хата-Майстерня,
ми точно знаємо, що будемо робити.
Я не знаю, яким чином ми визначили бюджет,
якось дуже приблизно.
І просто дивилися, як ми можемо між собою
та своїми знайомими ці гроші зібрати.
Тут була величезна підтримка.
Починаючи від якихось
моментів з краудфандингом
і завершуючи вкладом людей,
яким це стало дуже цікаво,
які приїжджали, копали землю,
глину перекидали, носили каміння.
Клали дорогу.
Бетонували підлогу, фарбували, лакували.
Ну, просто...
Звичайно, тут були й кваліфіковані майстри ,
але були й люди, які щось вміють, знають.
І вони просто тижнями тут працювали.
Без цього, мабуть, було б взагалі неможливо.
Хаті 70 років.
Господар, який збудував цю хату,
був у селі не те, щоб диваком,
а новатором —
був дуже хорошим майстром по дереву.
Навколо нього і цього місця завжди
крутилися якісь цікаві люди,
сюди приїжджали бойчукісти малювати.
Різні творчі особистості
були дотичними  до цього місця.
Так вийшло, що після того, як він помер,
згодом все почало занепадати через повені,
через те, що тут були певні природні катаклізми.
Зараз нам потрохи вдається
відновлювати зв'язок цього місця
з творчими людьми,
які сюди приїжджають і тут щось створюють.
Це Василь Балан — фотограф.
Хлопці, на Говерлу — у той бік.
[сміється]
— Привіт.
— Здоров.
Він майстер-класи організовував
для інших фотографів.
Дуже чітко запам'ятав той момент, коли нарешті
вже ніби все було готово, лиш не вистачало кранів.
Я поставив крани
і прийняв перший теплий душ!
[Віля Чупак
Співзасновник Хати-Майстерні]
Уперше повернувся за рік в Івано-Франківськ
з Хати-майстерні і не йшов в душ.
Мені жінка каже, щоб я йшов у душ.
А я їй: «А я вже був в душі!»
[сміються]
Ще, пам'ятаю, одного разу ми робили електрику,
я налаштував модем — і ми дивилися футбол тут!
Сиділи і дивилися футбол!
Зараз це вже по-іншому сприймається,
а тоді приїхав в гори собі,
попрацював і дивився кіно...
Мені завжди подобалося тут попити кави.
Дивишся, тут хата, там — село, гори.
Це місце мені було прикольне.
Це таке молодече бажання:
ще трохи — і буде кльово!
А потім зрозуміли,
що треба отримувати насолоду від процесу.
Просто класно, що ти працюєш з друзями,
що ти є такий...
Знаєш, як на кожній стадії є свій результат,
як я казав: запустили душ — супер,
під'єднали інтернет — супер.
Запустили телефон нарешті, то вже можна
додзвонитися, бо раніше не було як.
У місті все сприймається як
тобі дане і тебе нічого не обходить,
а тут ти все сам.
Ти маєш подумати,
і коли воно працює — тішишся
в цій системі.
Загалом хата зроблена в три яруси,
за такими принципами,
що другий поверх у нас для гостей.
Це нова частина, де раніше нічого не було, а тепер там є кімнати,
де може одночасно розміститися, здається,
двадцять чотири людини, і тут ще шість.
У нас майже щороку бувають планери художні.
Цього року весною у нас був
такий відкритий тиждень хати.
Це тиждень, коли ми робимо якусь програму,
і туристи можуть приїхати індивідуально,
тобто не групами, а поодинці, по двоє, по троє.
І щодня вони мають якусь цікаву активність.
В один з днів хлопці та дівчата
ходили в гори малювати.
І от кілька картин залишилось,
вони просто тут висять вже
як у живому музеї чи живій галереї.
Це, до речі, портрети господарів,
які цю хату побудували.
Просто сфотографовані
в різні періоди їхнього життя.
У нас тут усе доволі просто:
ми не ставили якихось броньованих дверей,
такий вільний відкритий простір.
Простір довіри.
У нас тут двері зі склом, можна подивитися...
Без зайвих замків.
Чим ще класне це місце:
з нього відкривається чудовий краєвид
у бік Косова,
у бік Коломиї, на гори.
Взимку, коли листя опадає,
то ще й проглядається цей бік хребта,
східний, і видно набагато далі.
Дуже красиво.
Це таке для мене певне серце Хати-Майстерні.
Колись це просто був сіновал і на початку,
коли ми сюди заїхали
і робили там [в Хаті-Майстерні] ремонт,
іноді тут спали, на сіні.
А потім повиносили сіно
і подивилися, що можна це місце використовувати
для того, аби тут люди могли навчатися.
Тут проходять мовні курси, тренінги,
тут проходили майстер-класи з танців.
Воно витримує десь 30 людей,
які скачуть народні танці.
Ми за це дуже хвилювалися.
Люди, які готували внизу, не знали до кінця,
чи воно витримає, але витримало.
Ми, однозначно, розширили
горизонт сприйняття частини місцевих жителів.
Ми вже почали працювати зі школою,
вже робимо деякі заходи в клубі,
в якому не проходило нічого вже,
не знаю, скільки років.
Ми співпрацюємо з місцевою школою:
іноді проводимо там теж якісь презентації.
Плюс ще деякі люди з нашої команди
ходять час від часу на засідання сільради,
тобто ми знаємо сільського голову і він нас знає.
Це особливо наш Тарас Грицюк і Саша Московчук.
Вони дуже вболівають за екологічну ситуацію,
за розділення сміття.
І взагалі, те, що тут сміття не вивозиться,
не розділяється —
просто скидається десь в гірські річки —
знаю, що нашим хлопцям дуже це болить.
Вони вже другий рік ходять на засідання сільради
і говорять, що можна змінити,
чим можна допомогти.
Чи можна якось організувати хоча б збір паперу
або збір скла тут, і його вивозити.
Тобто рішення ще немає, але хлопці
над цим постійно працюють.
Дізнаються, які фірми можуть вивозити,
що для цього потрібно,
як встановити контейнер і т.д.
Можливо, якщо ми згодом це зробимо,
це буде щось таке дуже намацувальне.
Не треба це сприймати виключно об'єктом і типу ремонтом.
Атракції розвивати, маршрут.
Он зараз там цей електробайк —
новий такий подих.
Ми маємо об'їздити тут довколишні місцини
і скласти мапи маршрутів.
Приходять люди і їм треба запропонувати,
що вони тут зможуть робити —
не сидіти в хаті чи семінар тільки проводити.
Треба базуватися на ресурсах Гуцульщини,
просто зробити маршрути, якими можна сходити,
наприклад, на Писаний Камінь.
Тут насправді можна дуже багато всього робити.
Думаю, для людей, які б хотіли кинути все в місті
і переїхати робити щось тут.
Ми відкриті, нам цікаві якісь партнерські пропозиції.
Це місце ніби майданчик,
який зможе в майбутньому багато чого породити,
якихось цікавих речей.
Це дуже органічний проєкт,
зараз є такі відчуття,
що в команди є енергія
щось в нього вкладати.
В якийсь момент, буде органічно, коли ми скажемо:
«Окей, тут ми задоволені, готові йти далі».
Чи частина команди піде і скаже:
«Ми підемо далі масштабувати»,
то вони підуть масштабувати.
А поки наша енергія, у мене таке враження,
ще є тут — ми хочемо ще тут розвинути.
Ось хлопці хочуть розвивати маршрути
і вони цим горять.
У нас ще є тут енергія,
ми хочемо її допрацювати до кінця.
А там будемо дивитися...
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Музика
Blooms Corda, Sasha Boole, Omodada Gee]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]